Creed 2 was directed by Stephen cable
jr. and follows Ryan Coogler extremely
good Creed which blew me away despite
following the formula of most rocky
films that film had so much heart and it
was just a massive surprise and it's one
of my favorite films in the rocky
franchise so going into Creed 2 I was a
bit nervous this has been a very
disappointing year for film a lot of
movies have let me down movies that I
was looking forward to and so I was
crossing my fingers going into this one
and in this film Creed is challenged by
Ivan Drago's son and if you've ever seen
rocky 4 you know there's a lot of bad
blood between the Drago's and Creed and
rocky so if you've never seen rocky 4 I
guess spoiler warning but Ivan Drago
killed Apollo in the ring and so there's
a lot of anger there from from Donnie in
this film and he really wants to avenge
his father's death and so the boxing
match that we're all hoping to see has a
lot more drama and a lot more weight
behind it personally for these
characters especially because this film
actually does a really great job of
fleshing out the drago family they're
not just the big strong bad guys who
glare at everyone and get really angry
and you want to see them get punched in
the face real good they actually set up
a lot of behind the scenes personal
drama with them and I was very taken
aback by that
and that's something about this movie
that felt very fresh when compared to
the other Rocky films I actually
understood the bad guys I understood
their position they have as much on the
line as Crede does in the movie so you
can almost get invested in both sides
and it makes it a considerably more
emotional experience than perhaps rocky
4 would have taken these characters if
this exact film was made in the late 80s
because this is a movie that takes the
rocky 4 characters and what went on
there a very cheesy very silly 80s movie
with hearts on fire which I still listen
to and is absolutely incredible by the
way I made a crappy rocky montage one
time with that song with my buddy John
Flickinger here's a clip
[Music]
this film takes those cheesy 80s
sweat-drenched roots which admittedly is
a major guilty pleasure of mine and
turns it into a grounded and realistic
film I really enjoyed this movie I had a
blast watching it I felt something this
movie made me feel something
my cold jaded heart was broken into by
this movie and I actually had emotions
and a lot of that is due to Michael B
Jordan who is one of the best actors of
his generation when that guy gets going
man
and he's got the tears flowing and and
he's just so energetic about what he
wants to do and he's so passionate this
character I just really feel for him and
I really kind of care about him and
Sylvester Stallone once again in the
role that is iconic for him gives a
fantastic performance as Rocky Balboa
because he has a nice arc in the film as
well dealing with his family and the
estrangement from his child and there's
a lot on his shoulders to this film
absolutely follows a formula that other
Rocky movies do and a lot of critics are
probably going to pinpoint that as a
problem this is the eighth movie in this
franchise I'd like to see a filmmaker
make a rocky film without a boxing match
without an inspirational training
montage
without wisdom bomb scenes and which
people talk and inspire each other and
say things that are meant to get you up
and get you pumped try making that movie
try making a rocky movie that doesn't
follow the formula of the rest and we'll
see if critics like it even the first
Creed film followed a very similar
formula to all the Rocky movies it just
did it with great care and really good
dialog and direction and incredible
fight scenes this film was directed by
Steven Capel jr. who inspires me for a
number of reasons one he made a damn
good movie he made actually a really
good sequel but he's also from Cleveland
where I'm from and he's a good filmmaker
from here and he's out there and he's
working and he's making good shit like
that's very inspiring to me someone who
is also since I was 14 been trying to
make short films and stuff like that and
trying to get my name out there - in
regards to filmmaking and so that's
super inspiring to me and I think he did
a great job with the film the boxing
matches are very white-knuckled there's
some really good POV shots nothing quite
as interesting as the one take that was
in Creed but I also understand that you
wouldn't want to just do another one
take sequence you want to put your own
stamp on this film Dolph Lundgren was
actually really excellent as Ivan Drago
again I must emphasize that these
villain characters were given a lot of
meat and they weren't just the bad guys
with muscles that punch things like they
really had a lot behind them and I
started to understand both sides Michael
B Jordan as I've already said is
terrific in this movie as is Stallone
Tessa Thompson also really emotional
performance fantastic work
I think these movies are spaced out in
just the right amount of time where you
have enough in between them to where you
are ready to see another inspirational
boxing movie that has similar themes and
similar scenes as the rest but they're
doing a good job of maintaining what the
first film's set up and even extending
his arc even more because he was a young
man under the shadow of his father who
wanted to prove himself he wanted to
prove that he wasn't a mistake in this
film he's proved that but now he has
this nagging thing that's that's under
the surface what happened to his father
and if there's some way he can kind of
make it right in his mind there's this
great scene between Michael B Jordan
Tessa Thompson where they're talking
about how boxing is what he knows how to
do it's what he loves he doesn't know
how to do anything else that well and
you can't ask him to stop that because
it's part of him he's passionate about
that and she understands that because
she's passionate about her music and so
they make a really nice couple as well
there's a lot of scenes where you feel
like you can totally feel that chemistry
and that's why I feel like maybe this
should be the last Creed film it
probably won't be but there's the fact
that this is a good movie and it's not a
terrible movie and it still maintains
the rocky legacy as well as the Creed
legacy and takes it to new heights in
regards to what they can do with that
character I feel like he's had his arc
and if they make another one it's gonna
get into the silly territory like they
did in the 80s after rocky -
you know that kind of maintained the
storyline but then rocky 3 was kind of
sillier than rocky 4 was really silly
and so I feel like it'd be a good idea
for them to just leave it at this
because this was a good send-off if they
do another one we'll see what happens
but I was really pleased with this movie
I think it's a really well done boxing
film that is admittedly formulaic but do
you want to not see inspiring shit when
you go to these movies I mean I think
this is a damn good movie and I am proud
that the filmmakers from Cleveland I'm
gonna give Creed - and a - guys thank
you so much as always for watching look
forward to more reviews very soon as
well as an interview with Steven Capel
jr. I was able to meet him and talk to
him for a while we talked about
filmmaking short films Sundance all
kinds of stuff really a genuine guy like
super real I was really happy to be able
to meet him and talk to him and that
interview will be up in a few days guys
thank you so much as always for watching
look forward to more very soon and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]